and you also mentioned about turning off
lightning which I thought was
interesting I was just out at the clock
say where we're building the clock and
we have a big huge crane tower at the
top that's attached to all of us humans
effectively because we're all on the
crane platform and whenever there was
lightning within five miles we had to
stop working and and obviously lightning
causes destruction around the world on
some level and fires forest fires for
better or worse depending on where you
are what do you think that there's a
plausible scenario for being able to
control lightning on that level I think
it's worth looking at because as I
mentioned lightning uses this gain
mechanism it doesn't have enough feel to
generate lightning to start but this
relativistic electron Avalanche has a
net gain and usually something like that
that has gained it's pretty easy to
wreck it and all you have to do is wreck
it to reconcile that change to stop the
chain reaction and not the lightning is
that theory the widely accepted theory
at this point or is that it's not still
a fairly it's one of them a terrific
Innes Ivan's runaway breakdown is one of
the main contenders however it doesn't
explain a few things
apparently it doesn't have quite enough
gain to actually start a real lightning
strike which is anywhere from thirty
thousand to one hundred twenty thousand
amps however Dwyer came up with a really
novel mechanism where the gamma rays
facing downwards can produce positron
electron pairs just like in the NASA
video but heading downwards and if you
make a positron in that electric field
it heads back upstream because it's
positively charged and history is it can
make it upstream far enough to where it
eventually does hit something and
annihilates it'll produce more
relativistic electrons upstream again
and it forms kind of this positronic
feedback loop that could greatly
increase the current in the Avalanche
that was the point where I said no I
can't believe positrons
[Laughter]
[Music]